the first trailer for Marvel's The
Avengers infinity war has finally
dropped and it's as much of a doozy as
fans might have expected not only do we
finally see the many new subsets of
superheroes come together with the og
Avengers but Thanos has finally decided
to step down from his space throne and
take a shot at gathering those Infinity
stones and from the looks of this
trailer he's off to a good start let's
take a look at some of the finer details
you might have missed in the trailer for
Avengers infinity war
Loki's betrayal the events of Thor
Ragnarok might have brought Thor and
Loki to a cheeky date hunt but it's just
a matter of time before brother dearest
betrayed that newly earned trust this
new trailer shows Loki handing over the
tesseract to someone who is probably
Thanos or one of his minions and if that
isn't bad enough it also shows him
stepping over a bunch of bodies to do so
could that giant ship that arrived in
the Bleak mid-credits scene after
Ragnarok truly have heralded Thanos
arrival and if so will it mean the
destruction of the remaining as
guardians Thor does seem pretty broken
up and the glimpses we get of him here
he's sporting a patch to conceal the
damage he'll it did to his eye in
Ragnarok and he seems to be trying to
fight something well above his pay grade
by pushing against the levers on some
massive machine he's later shown looking
through a spaceship window which might
be on the guardians Milano and when he
finally does meet star-lord and his
alien crew Thor seems lonelier and more
contemptuous than ever if our hunch is
right about Loki it's not hard to guess
why Thor would be in such a bad mood a
new villain there are two flashes in the
Avengers infinity war trailer that point
to a new villain in one Captain America
all decked out in black and bearded is
shown tussling with someone who looks a
lot like Proxima midnight a member of
Thanos Black Order then we see poor
vision having his head zapped by a
golden staff that looks an awful lot
like the one owned by Corvus glaive in
the comics this Grim Reaper esque
villain is a faithful servant of Fanus a
member of his Black Order and is known
for having a magical connection with his
glaives blade which appears to do his
terrible bidding against vision here
Spidey's new digs it looks like
spider-man plays a big part in trying to
shut down the portal
or whatever that device that's hanging
over the city will be called and we'll
be doing so in his fancy new iron spider
suit and that's not the only thing
that's new about Spider Man in this
movie he's also shown on a school bus
experiencing his spider sense in the
form of raised arm hair which alerts
them to the fact that the city's just
been invaded by the looming sky ring of
doom
well Conda here we come Avengers
infinity war won't be the first film to
make landfall in Wakanda of course since
we first saw the country in civil wars
mid-credits scene Black Panthers release
date precedes the infinity war by
several months as well but it does look
like the gang will recruit to chawla and
a coy way to join their Super Hero Squad
there are several glimpses of Wakanda
throughout the trailer which include one
big battle that will feature Captain
America the Winter Soldier the Black
Widow Hulk and more gasps Bruce isn't
having trouble transitioning back and
forth into Hulk the way he feared he
might be in thor ragnarok hand-to-hand
although Thanos has been a pretty
hands-off kind of space-filling until
now he decided in the mid credit scene
for Avengers age of Ultron that he was
going to take matters into his own hands
before gloving up with a Venn unjú
Infinity Gauntlet and it looks like he's
going to make good on that promise in
Avengers infinity war because he's shown
personally bringing the pain to some of
our heroes chief among his victims is
spider-man who seems to take quite a
beating from our intergalactic baddie of
course the final showdown will probably
be a little more spectacular than either
of these clips but it's still clearly
very personal for Thanos right now
speaking of which vanos has stones
before this movie it wasn't clear that
Thanos would have any Infinity stones to
add to his gauntlet or whether he'd even
gotten the real gauntlet this time as
expected though the fact that it's on
his left hand now shows that it is not
only the real deal but he's been able to
add at least two stones to it the first
stone is purple which seems to indicate
that he's retrieved the Power Stone
Ronan tried to keep for himself and
guardians of the galaxy but which ended
up securely at Nova Corps headquarters
the second one is blue which probably
means it's the space stone Loki is shown
passing along earlier we don't know if
we'll be able to gather the yellow mine
stone from vision or the green time
stone from Doctor Strange but he's still
farther along in a
Qwest and many fans might have expected
by now there was a leaked teaser image
in 2014 that indicated that US would
eventually gather all the stones at some
point but it's not clear whether that'll
happen in this movie or in Avengers 4
which is due in 2019 one thing we do
know is that it'll all add up to a heck
of a fight for our heroes one that's
destined to end and what Marvel chief
Kevin Feige has described as a finale
for the MCU as we know it thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all the school stuff we know
you'll love to
[Music]